So Nelsmah, let's talk about what context is. When we say context, we mean
the context of the user, who's using
your application on their Android smart phone.
>> Yeah let's break it down into four things. The first aspect of context
is, what is your user doing? Are they walking, running? Are they sleeping? Are
they sitting? So the second part of context is, where is the user? This
can be derived from GPS and you can get their latitude and longitude and
there is information about the environmental conditions of where they're at
that has an impact on this as well. So the third
aspect of context is who or what is your user near?
These are things like places that are near by. They're in a
shopping mall, the stores they can visit. Or it's also people
that they're nearby. So you can get this information from their
circles and so on. The last and most obvious part of
context is, who is your user? We can get this information if
your user signed into Google+. We can get their
name, their profile photo, when they were born, all kinds
of things that they put in their profile. And we
can also get who their friends are from their circles.
>> So taking a lot of these aspects
of user context into account. What application have you
used that got one of these or multiple of
these really right and it totally blew your mind?